when I was about
eight years old
some kid in the third grade told me that
Santa Claus wasn't real and that was
just my parents
coming and bringing presents and I think
ever since then it lit a flame in me
that
I would like to make young children
believe that their presence on Christmas
morning are being brought to them by a
large rotund man in a red suit
[Music]
hi I'm David Harbor and this is how I
became Santa Claus
[Music]
it was pretty intense you know the
training that we did uh
I trained for a couple months with these
guys at 87 North and it was uh pretty
pretty intense there's a lot of like
Greco-Roman wrestling in Jiu Jitsu and
stuff and it was a it was a lot of
training a lot of fight training yeah
I've done some training for movies
before but not specifically this
particular Jiu Jitsu training I really
did like that uh we call it the tinsel
fight in the movie there's a fight where
around the pool table and where I uh
finally take out this character of
tinsel and that I really enjoyed that
fight you know oddly enough uh I had to
do more fighting as Santa Claus than as
red Guardians so I would say uh
I would say Santa Claus is the tougher
the tougher role it's pretty brutal I
mean they're both clearly you know great
set piece fighting movies but uh what I
was doing in violent night was very very
intense compared to what I was doing
Marvel but maybe yeah it was very brutal
my Santa Claus fight experiences
Santa Claus is Coming to Town
[Music]
since beatings
what is the most bad thing about Santa
Claus
God what isn't bad about Santa Claus I
mean he literally rides around
on a sleigh with magical flying reindeer
and has
an enormous sack
in which he can pull out anything he
wants gifts for anyone in the world
just about everything Santa Claus does
is pretty badass but um
yeah I don't know I mean I guess I'd say
I guess I'd say flying around on uh on a
sleigh with magical reindeers pretty bad
they have a very close relationship
Santa Santa and his reindeer they're
very tight you know and uh they yeah he
they magically sort of do understand
English so
yeah I'd like that power
I think once we finally put the whole
look together and we had like the you
know the wig and the beard and the whole
suit the finally slung the bag over my
shoulder I showed up for uh that first
day of shooting I finally put the
glasses on finally felt like Santa Claus
it's very exciting
we decided that you could have one gift
early
what is it that is a direct hotline of
Santa Claus himself
all right revelers
welcome back to your worst Christmas
ever let's go yeah I mean I do remember
when I was growing up and you
um came downstairs
and saw that the cookies were half eaten
and the milk was half drunk and the like
carrots
were nibbled on I remember that feeling
that that was like forensic evidence
that like Santa Claus was in your house
and it was indisputable that there was a
man delivering presents in your house
that was quite
quite amazing to me a favorite
unconventional holiday tradition well
like when I was growing up I remember
um I grew up in a house and we didn't
have a chimney
and we've and I was very confused as a
kid
how Santa Claus was gonna get in our
house without a chimney
and I was very annoyed by this and my
mom told me that he'd come in from the
back back door and so we would leave the
back door open on Christmas Eve and like
prop it up a little bit and I remember
that being a very sweet thing that my
mom and I used to do for Christmas
what's the best holiday gift I ever
received when I was uh uh four years old
my uh
my aunt in Texas got me milky the cow
and milky was a cow that you could
assemble and you could milk
the cow and uh it took my dad about 12
hours of setup
to get me to milk that cow that was the
hardest gift ever put together but God I
love that thing so much so
uh thank you Aunt Barbara and dad for
the assembly
I don't want any trouble okay
Something's Gonna scooch up that chimney
what I really love about this movie is
that um
he's a man with a past you know I think
what we start to see about Santa Claus
is there's more than meets the eye you
know we think he's this big fat jolly
man in a suit and then as it starts to
unravel there's so much depth and
complexity and craziness to
to who Santa was and what made him want
to start delivering presents in the
first place so
yeah uh that's what I liked about this
movie you know Santa is clearly like
a guy who has some really uh crazy
skills you know he knows his way around
uh fighting in a certain way and so
where did that come from who was this
guy and years ago he was a he was an
entirely different man until he found
the elves up at the North Pole and
started giving presents away to kids and
so you know that guy was very very
interesting guy I would pair uh the
original Miracle on 34th Street with
violent night because I feel like they
both are
real
investigations of whether or not Santa's
real in many different ways you know on
one side you have
John leguizamo's villain sort of
questioning the Integrity of the reality
of this brutal Santa Claus and then on
the other you have this mother who's
very connectologic sort of telling her
daughter that she shouldn't believe in
frivolous things and it's uh
kind of a nice little parallel what if
he really is the real no such thing as
Santa
and what do you do to the naughty ones I
give my love for cold
where is this
[Music]
if I Believe In You Santa here's what I
think is naughty or nice
I seem to find my toothbrush so I'll
pick one up when I go out today other
than that I'm in good shape
Kevin costume Home Alone that kid is
nice I mean he does like take out bad
guys so God bless Kevin McAllister keep
the change you filthy animal you're not
really Santa if you were saying that you
could do magic you want to see some
magic here let's watch you disappear a
willy and Bad Santa is
I mean he's just clearly pretty naughty
not anymore
that I feel so much better now Jack's
going to feel like got a bad rep for
being he's like a pretty nice sweet guy
and he just got this like horrible
reputation so you know he's nice he's
nice
[Music]
[Applause]
trouble man I knew you'd save me
wow I don't think I remember that movie
all I remember is like
the trailer of him like jumping at a
video game and like sinbads there like
blocking him or something so I really I
can't weigh in you know I can't weigh in
whether he's probably nice I have no
idea what what he's been doing all year
long I have no idea
yeah I'm still here
unless you want to open the front door
for me
yeah John McLean and die hard is like
I mean he's just super nice there's just
no question
[Music]